Qué significan estos movimientos de
parte de Rusia Se confirma que Ucrania
está retomando en semanas territorio que
a Moscú le costó mucho más tiempo
controlar
Muy buenas tardes Valentina saludarte y
sin duda estamos viendo una gran
cantidad de movimientos militares tanto
al norte como al este y al sur durante
las últimas semanas estamos ya a casi
200 días de cumplir del inicio de esta
guerra Y estos movimientos que se dan
pues son anuncios por parte del ejército
ucraniano donde declaran que ya están
recuperando parte del territorio perdido
que es prácticamente hacia el este así
esta región controlada por rusos esta
región procesa denominada con base y
estas ciudades Pues habían estado bajo
el control ruso pero pareciera que ahora
hay un repliegue comparta las tropas
rusas y hay un avanzada por parte del
ejército ucraniano Pero esto todavía no
delinea un triunfo por parte de Ucrania
ni tampoco podemos asegurar que está
perdiendo Rusia simplemente es continuar
esta agonía y ya
eso ya vamos a cumplir 200 días y sin un
Horizonte que se acerque la paz pronto
lo hagan en ti Cuál es la estrategia que
está usando Ucrania en esta
contraofensiva
Fíjate que me parece que esto es el
resultado de toda la ayuda que ha estado
recibiendo por parte de otras naciones
ese resultado de financiamiento por
parte de Estados Unidos que cada semana
abona grandes cantidades de millones de
dólares y ahora cuenta con otro tipo de
armas ha recibido equipo por parte de
países aliados para poder hacer frente
también a las nuevas armas que el
ejército ruso está incursionando Estados
Unidos decía la semana pasada que Irán
le había vendido drones a Rusia para
estar atacando territorio ucraniano y
que había información de inteligencia
que apuntaban a que Corea del Norte le
estaba vendiendo equipo a Rusia y que
inclusive se tenían las conversaciones
de que Corea del Norte pudiera abonar a
ejército para sumarse al ejército ruso
entonces pareciera que son de que ambas
partes están pidiendo
pero que sin duda Ucrania Pues cuenta
con más respaldo con más tecnología que
lo que pareciera está teniendo el
ejército ruso hoy un líder pero ruso
Indicó que incluso en la región de
Donnie es la situación para Moscú es
difícil A qué se refiere
7 Valentina que va de hechos hay varios
haciendo ciertas declaraciones donde
consideran que cada vez Rusia está
acercándose a un fin que está ya agotado
el ejército Ruso y que también las
reservamos están agotando y ellos
de acuerdo a su perspectiva Rusia
que se está acercando posiblemente al
fin de de esta guerra sin embargo esto
yo no estoy tan segura ni tan convencida
de que Rusia esté ganando está perdiendo
por completo porque sigue teniendo su
arma su estratégica que solo se
energéticos sigue alterando la crisis
energética y delineando todas estas
convulsión de crisis no solamente hacia
Europa sino a diferentes partes del
mundo con la de los granos y afectando
también los precios internacionales del
gas natural y de ahí es que vemos
que por más declaraciones que haya y de
un lado del otro al final lo más triste
es que la guerra continúe y que un
escenario posible de paz cada vez se ve
mucho más le